hé tout le monde euh on est extrêmement triste d'
avoir raté d23 mais on travaille
très dur sur le prochain film de Deadpool depuis
euh un bon bout de temps maintenant
j'ai dû vraiment chercher mon âme sur
celui-ci euh sa première apparition dans le
Le MCU doit évidemment se sentir spécial, nous
devons rester fidèles au personnage euh en
achetant une nouvelle profondeur et une nouvelle motivation,
ce qui signifie que chaque Deadpool doit se
démarquer et se démarquer, cela a été un
défi incroyable qui m'a forcé
à aller au plus profond de moi et je
n'ai rien
ici  juste complètement
vide ici
et terrifiant mais nous avons eu une idée
hey Hugh tu veux jouer Wolverine une
fois de plus
ouais bien sûr
[Musique]
étranger